[Music]
black shirt
squad well maybe you guys think alike
and dress alike because you've known
each other for
how long now whoa uh was it in 1994
that the show started it's going on 30
years now
right yeah it's like 28 years wow
when it was like 14 15. yeah
well and i actually have a really fun
question
that i'm so interested to hear because i
know
that there is and all that reboot that's
happening
and am i correct and that you guys are
also producing it
that's right that's right we're both
executive producers on it
and they are deep into their first
season they've done uh
they started with 10 and then they've
re-upped another 10 i think two times or
something like that so yeah
and the kids are wonderful and kale's
been there he's done
you know the good burger sketch like 16
times so far
you know what i mean he's been able to
be there on a daily basis because he's
on the west coast and
it's been a beautiful thing you guys
were kid actors
i was a kid actor and now we're parents
what do you say to the kids what's your
guidance what's your
like wisdom and how do you handle it i
told them
uh when i first met them at the table
read of course we saw their auditions
but i told them remember that you
were made perfect and this was the thing
before you were born
all right so before you were born you
are already perfect this is not the
thing that's going to make you perfect
this is not the thing that's going to
change you this is part of a long
journey
and what do you tell your kids though if
they wanted to get into acting
well i have a very strong line of
communication
with them about it and that is that
i don't want them on social media or i
don't show them
because look i have all sorts of
wonderful baggage that i would never let
go of
or have it any other way because i
wouldn't be exactly who i am
at this moment in time without all those
experiences and i'm always trying to
kind of
keep them just grounded and not feeling
privileged and as
sort of figuring out what is important
and appropriate
and i just say to them do school stuff
do school plays be in the arts and then
sometime around i don't know 14 to 16
you will know who you are as a person
and whatever that is that you choose i
will
support it i would be the first person
to help them
but like maybe not before 14 15.
what age did you start 11 months
when did you guys get your start at
exactly what age
ooh uh i i started out in
a theater when i was about i want to say
uh
12 like 12 years old you know because i
was doing everything in the classroom
and i was a bit of a class clown and my
parents were like
okay we have to find something and they
put me into a community theater
and then i was like oh this is it this
is what i was looking for
like keenan i know you got started very
young younger than
me on the news right i mean it was only
doing like school and church
type stuff but i do remember like
community theater really being like a
turning point where i noticed that this
was like a real
profession did you guys have the head
sheet where you have to like
have three different expressions so you
can sell like i'm serious
i'm crazy and i'm something else
grab bag that was for the commercial
kids but we could only
afford like one picture at a time so it
was just
one good pose with a sweater just a nice
young man
and so when you're on all that and
you're doing the sketches
and they're clicking and they're working
and people are responding to it
and they come to you and they say we
want to make a movie out of this
what is your first what was your first
reaction oh wow
it was always oh wow yeah i mean like
let's do this
we put in mad work so it just it felt
good to be
appreciated in that kind of initiative
to want to make a movie out of a sketch
but also
have the movie be so beloved too it's
just been incredible
it was crazy i mean like uh for because
good burger started to like
you know gain a lot of steam a lot of
the musical guests wanted to be in like
the good burger sketches
uh and then keenan was very helpful for
me too because this was my first movie
and keenan had already did you already
done
mighty ducks right at that point yeah
yeah so
because this was like my first film so i
was like man what should i expect so
this was really cool man uh remember
that bro when we were driving down
sunset
i think with uh rava and we were driving
down and we saw
uh the big billboard uh with that was
cut out of a super super giant size and
we were surfing on the pickle
it was like above the top of the
billboard and below the bottom of it so
it was like a real
cut out type special billboard thing i
remember that
i think we pulled over yeah of course we
took pictures
i find the most fun fact that brian
robbins who was in head of the class
which was like a welcome back carter
kind of show
almost and he was the vinnie barberino
character
and that was a big show when we were all
young
and then he was the director of good
burger
and now is the president of nickelodeon
it's crazy
crazy i know that you guys have keenan
and cal
2020 t-shirts oh yeah i do
oh yeah can i ask what a keenan and cal
presidency would look like it would look
better than how it's looking right now
it'll be a lot of orange soda involved a
lot of orange soda
but i would really want to just like
settle down all of the
like anxiety but also all of the anger
and misinformation
make love mandatory love and you gotta
smile when you go walking around
say say when you wear your mask you
gotta say i'm smiling under this mask
tyra banks created smizing um
for america's next top model and i wanna
ask her
teach me the art of smizing because i'm
such a smiler
i definitely think uh we have to do a
lot of eye
acting now to communicate joy
it's like this it's like this it's like
can either of you wink both eyes i can
only wink the one
both eyes both eyes yeah
that could be something to do under a
mask
well i know that you guys had a good
burger pop-up
um done by none other than alvin
kalin who is one of
my favorite chefs in the world and i
actually
was lucky enough this is his new
cookbook you guys made a pact that you
would
never reveal what was in ed's special
sauce
that's right that's right yeah
it's cool it's probably mostly because
we don't know
alvin would actually look at the movie
and pause it
and stop it and start it trying to
figure out what ed's special sauce was
do you mind if i bring him in really
quickly so you guys can say hello and
then alvin and i are going to cook some
good burgers together
evan
what's up bro i'll be the presence of
greatness right now
so you know uh you know i'm just gonna
make some good burgers because it's one
of my favorite movies
i've traveled across the country around
the world
tasting different burgers and so like
every all of this
came in together and it's it's just
perfect timing we're gonna make two
burgers we're gonna
make the classic alvin good burger of
course
because um and then alvin and i decided
to make a french onion soup burger
for something different because a burger
is the most
dynamic thing it can be anything you
want it to be it has so many
interpretations
thank you guys so much and i am
so happy to say that for this thursday
night on nickelodeon
for two hours straight everyone can just
enjoy the good stuff in life
representing you
yes thank you very much and you all have
a great day everybody yeah